this morning belarus's president
defended his move to divert a commercial
flight and forced it to land in his
country
it was his first public comment since a
dissident journalist and his girlfriend
were taken off the plane and arrested on
sunday
the move led to sanctions by the
european union charlie dagada reports on
belarus's effort
to justify what other officials are
calling a hijack
president alexander lukashenko came out
swinging today accusing the west of
crossing a red line
strangling belarus and saying it was a
total lie that the plane was forced down
defiance expected of the man nicknamed
the last
dictator in europe he doubled down that
it was a bomb threat that forced that
ryanair passenger
plane down on sunday western leaders
believe it was instead a plot to arrest
opposition
activist roman protosevich seen hearing
what appeared to be a forced confession
released
monday
in a transcript released by lukashenko's
government the ryanair pilot repeatedly
questions the controller over the force
diversion the pilot asks
this recommendation to divert to minsk
where did it come
from where did it come from company
departure airport authorities
arrival airport authorities the
controller just replies
this is our recommendation overnight
another video appeared showing
protosavich's companion sophia sopaga
apparently under duress confessing to
being the editor of an anti-government
social media channel
friends and family now fear for their
lives
mother natalia made an urgent plea to
world leaders
i am begging for help i'm begging for
help she says
please save him they're going to kill
him in there
she has not heard from her son roman
since he was detained
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
london